well going in this was a classic case of
just war there was an act of aggression
the invasion of a country the invasion
of a member of the UN and we organized
the coalition to resist and throw back
the invasion and then we stopped and in
classic Just War theory that's what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
defeat the aggression and repeal it and
and then stop you don't you don't March
you don't have to overthrow the gut the
aggressive government that's for the
people to do if they want to do it and
we we stopped but then we incited a
rebellion inside Iraq leading people to
expect since we had an army right there
that we would help the rebels and then
we didn't and there was mass murder the
Saddam who had been unable to fight
against the the coalition army was
perfectly capable of fighting against
and slaughtering his own his own people
and he did on a very large scale in the
south and later in the north so yes we
behaved very badly and some of the
troubles that we've had in Iraq after 03
come from the the loss of confidence of
trust that we that we produced by our
behavior in 90